اظن اظن اخي احمد ان المكان الذي اعيش فيه
يوميا
يملى علي نظره معينه او شكلا من اشكال
النظافه
الى المساء وفي الليل ايضا
واصبحت لي علاقه خاصه
وسريه مع هذا النهار
طبعا في الكتاب
واضح جدا انني احاوره هذا النهر ويحاورني
على امتداد الزمان
وتدريجيا بدات اشعار كانوا ان النهر له
نوع من الحنين الى نبعه يريد ان يعود
الى الرحم
ولكن في نفس الوقت هو مندفع
سريره النهائي الاخير سيلقي بنفسه في
المحيط الاطلسي
وتحول هذا النهر الى استعاره للزمن
كان هذا النهر لا يمضي من هناك وانا اتامل
من بعيد فانه يخترقني
مع النهر مع الزمن وهذا النهر طبيعه الحال
يشبهني الى حد بعيد انت بتقول في النهر
يعرف لابد له من تضحيات
اذا يتنازل عن بعضه في الطريق
في الطريق يفاوض الروافد
ويمضي
[موسيقى]
ايضا صحيح